paris's historic former Stock Exchange
the setting for a two-day Summit hosted
by the French President aimed at
discussing ways to modernize the world's
Financial system to make it fairer for
developing nations struggling with debt
and the climate emergency
inequalities are on the rise climate
vulnerability is adding further risk and
our world is subject to ever increasing
shocks
what is required of us now
is absolute transformation and not
reform of our institutions
and that transformation is required
because while the world knew since the
1890s
that we were facing the warming of the
climate
we choose not to heed the advice of
scientists leaders are discussing
proposals to reform Financial lending
institutions including the World Bank
and international monetary fund to give
developing countries more say they're
also looking at ways to increase private
and public investment in poorer Nations
and expand green financing at the end of
this Summit leaders are expected to
deliver what they call a road map for
change but some activists say that
promises and good intentions simply are
not enough to address the Urgent needs
of developing countries
this activist says developed countries
need to step up and take responsibility
it's not lack of awareness anymore
everybody wants a cleaner green
environment but where is the money and
the reason they are developing country
because they don't have resources and
rich countries have to get that and we
don't see that perspective really coming
out clearly from rich countries that we
need to provide a helping hand and
especially recognizing it's the rich
countries who have caused the problem in
the first place
it's their development model Emmanuel
macron says no country should have to
choose between tackling poverty or
fighting climate change few would
disagree but unless wealthier countries
do more to help poorer Nations will
continue to face difficult choices
Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Paris